[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
yeah
so nice to be here I've traveled many
places finally I'm in a city where my
hair is big enough to fit in ladies and
gentlemen you guys invented this now
I've been we've traveled a lot of places
right Andy I'm gonna try my hardest ever
to give you people a great show you know
why because I know you're armed all
right
you have an extra gun sharing with the
person next to you people I'm learning
so much about your city I've studied you
know that Dallas officially became a
city in 1871 two-storey yeah that was
the year the founding fathers broke
ground on the first Whataburger yeah
[Applause]
that song
that's pretty sexy ladies that that what
a burger sauce going down
what a great sports town this is that
what a great sports town it is today is
opening day for Major League Baseball
opening day by the way just an hour ago
the Houston Astros were mathematically
eliminated
that's hard to do on opening day great
to be here in Dallas for the final four
congratulations on having the final four
of course in Texas the final four refers
to the number of Democrats in the
legislature thank you thank you yeah I'm
here all week thank you
of course Sports is not the only thing
you have in this town Dallas is home to
many incredible art museums just
incredible yeah yes and while I'm here I
plan to drive by all of them
you know every city in Texas of course
has their own motto the city of Austin's
motto is keep Austin weird yeah I prefer
Dallas's motto keep that weird [ __ ] in
Austin
[Applause]